في الوقت الذي يستغرقه قول هذه
الجملة ، سوف تجيب Yahoo على 79000
طلب معلومات حول العالم ، أي حوالي 6
مليارات في السنة ،
ترقبوا
ذلك قبل ثلاث سنوات فقط ،
اخترق الطالبان في علوم الكمبيوتر
برنامج كمبيوتر لمساعدتهما في العثور على الأشياء التي
أعجبتهما على الإنترنت  لقد أصبحت
شائعة حقًا ، لقد كانت أداة مهمة
وكان عليهم أن يفعلوا شيئًا مع هذه
الفكرة وقت الأزمة ، هل يتخلصون من المدرسة
ويذهبون إلى العمل ، وربما كان أكبر
صراع هو التخلي عن
شيء كنا نقوم به لمدة خمس
سنوات من القيام به  Phds ،
وكادوا أن يكونوا هناك قفزوا أولاً
بدعم من مستثمرين من القطاع الخاص ، ثم من خلال
بيع الأسهم ، أصبح الرجلان الآن يساويان
120 مليون دولار لكل منهما
المال لا يتدرج ،
فالمسئولية خارجة عن
شعار Yahoo تعني أن الصندوق داخل الرسائل يوضح
الحذر حيث  اختصار داخلي
نقول أه أيها الأشخاص لديك دائمًا
خيارات أخرى وأه نذكر ذلك كطريقة
متواضعة لقول ذلك ، أنت تعلم إذا
لم نفعل ما يريد الناس منا أن نراه
هو أننا لا نتصرف بناءً على ما يفعله الناس  يريدون أن
يروا أنهم يذهبون دائمًا إلى مكان آخر ، لكنهم
يأتون في الوقت الذي يستغرقه
قول هذه الجملة ، ستجيب Yahoo على
79000 طلب معلومات حول العالم حوالي
6 مليارات في السنة ، وهو ما لم أكن أتوقعه حقًا هو
أنه ربما
تتطلب
الكثير من الاهتمام الفوري من المكاتب
التي تبدو وكأنها غرف نوم في ستانفورد.وظف
Philo و yang 170 شخصًا
للعثور على كتالوج يصف ويصنف
ملايين العناصر على شبكة الويب العالمية.
Yahoo كشركة ليس لديها
مشرفون تقريبًا ونحن نقوم بالكثير من
الإدارة في الممرات مثل 6K for
Country ، أليس كذلك نحن فعلنا ذلك لأننا قمنا
ببعض المشاغبين الذين تعلمون أنني أستطيع الدخول إلى
مكعب أي شخص وأقول مرحبًا دعني أرتد
شيئًا عنك ما رأيك
في هذا ، حسنًا ، يتخطى البعض الممرات
بعضًا  تخطي الأحذية الجديدة التي لا يحتاجها Gold Rush
جريج لافاف CNN Santa Clara California
[موسيقى]